we certainly are experiencing a
challenging situation
but we are surging resources and we have
a multi-prong
approach to this we have sent a very
clear message
early on in light of the fact that we
are in the midst of a pandemic
that the border is not open
and people should not take the perilous
journey here we are returning uh people
to other countries
yep that's what he says uh dhs secretary
mark is pressed on the thousands of
migrants camped under that bridge in del
rio texas as he the secretary prepares
to visit the area himself for a
first-hand look
he's not going to like it uh texas
attorney general ken paxton joins us
right now from texas mr attorney general
good morning
good morning so we just heard from the
secretary said we sent a very clear
message the border is not open and yet
that's not the message they're getting
is it
no and that is not the message they've
sent from day one president biden said
you're welcome to come here we will not
deport you and that message was sent
loud and clear and haitians have been
given special protection they're not
being deported the ones that are already
here and so the the administration has
even told them
you know the ones that are here we're
not deporting so that message has gotten
through and that's why you see
that picture on the border with
thousands of people waiting to get in
well that just goes to show you how
uneven the uh application of of the
rules is because if he gave the haitians
temporary protected status and now he's
sending them back he says yeah i changed
my mind you know that explains why the
haitians are saying hey stop sending
them here we don't have room for our own
people
no that's exactly right i mean there is
a reason that they're the haitians are
here he invited him by giving them that
special protection
and that message got sent through their
community and that's why you saw
somebody show up so quickly and that's
the type of message he's been sending
since day one of his administration well
we understand that apparently they sent
three flights of migrants back from san
antonio yesterday there could be six
flights later today as they try to
look like we're sending them back they
can't you know it's going to take a
hundred planes to send that many people
back ultimately
as the people get off there in haiti but
mr attorney general when when you hear
them say all right we've we've closed
the border
but that just amounted to some of your
guys uh
at that dam where people were walking
across and some
also apparently a couple of mexican
police on the other side saying
it's closed here but they're coming in
across the river about a mile down
yeah that's a joke those people know how
to get through
they've made no real effort to stop them
if you just look at the immigration
numbers in general we're over two
hundred thousand last month over two
hundred thousand a month before that's a
three hundred percent increase so this
idea that somehow they're blocking the
haitians they're not blocking the
haitians any more than they're blocking
everybody else they they want illegal
immigration they want what that brings
and it's clear from how their actions
what their actions are that's that's
true what do you make of the senate
parliamentarian handing the senate
democrats and the white house a big loss
yesterday in saying that the democrats
cannot jam
some sort of immigration reform or
pathway for citizenship for people here
in their gigantic 3.5 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill that's not really
about infrastructure
well you know what at least there's
something right going in washington
typically you have to have germaness or
some type of connection
to a bill and if you're going to stick
immigration on this other stimulus bill
or whatever it is it has to be jermaine
i'm glad the parliamentarian ruled
correctly sure you've been watching
what's going on on our southern border
for years on a scale of one to ten
how bad is it now
so i would have to say i have never seen
it this bad i mean we've been
complaining about it for decades and and
the federal government has ignored it
other than the four years that donald
trump was in office and what's
remarkable is he had so many good
policies whether it was a stay in mexico
program whether it was the stopping the
catch and release the building of the
wall the the resources that went into it
and now we've taken all the offset
policies and getting the opposite
results so
my guess is this is exactly what the
biden administration wants
well and the secretary is coming your
way to uh eyeball it himself uh ken
paxton the ag for tx sir thank you very
much
thank you have a great day hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now